[Musique]
l'atelier de costumes de l'opéra de
montréal est une véritable caverne d'ali
baba et de cette caverne
on vendra 2000 des quatorze mille
trésors des costumes des accessoires
comme ce morceau qui a servi dans un
célèbre hôtel au vendra aussi cette
longue robe qu'on a vu dans la cnr
ntolla de rossini ça sera pas des
fortunes non plus parce que ça va
vraiment hâte et les plus chères - comme
à 150-200 c'est vraiment la sortie de
quad extraordinaire mais c'est pas ça
c'est vraiment c'est de ça que je dirais
la majorité va être à 50 10 20 dollars
cela c'est notre stock opéra l'atelier
déborde
il faut faire de la place l'opéra veut
donc se débarrasser des inutiles
doublons comme ce casque de l'opéra la
belle hélène
on a laissé les quatre de ceux qui ont
besoin d'un petit peu de rafistoler
sommes toujours au chapitre des
accessoires
il ya des morceaux de production célèbre
qu'on vendra à prix modique
ça ne sert à rien de garder un vieux
aida surtout on a décollé le bijou on a
réutilisé
c'est quoi que on aimerait faire dans le
futur
certains de ces costumes ont coûté à
l'origine près de 5000 $ à confectionner
le grand costumier qui a déjà une
collection de 100 mille pièces compte
bien mettre la main sur certains trésors
de l'opéra dans notre cas ce qu'on
recherche peut-être un petit peu plus
c'est ce qu'on appelle des vêtements des
pièces de base ont des chemises d'époque
des vêtements d'époque des trucs qui ne
sont pas flamboyants mais qui sont
recherchées beaucoup par les productions
sont peut les descendre des blanches
cette vente de costumes survient à un
mois de l'halloween et c'est voulu
nous on s'attend à ce que les gens
soient l'auto et en a même qui ont dit
qu'ils touchent au bureau vendredi soir
pour être le très tôt samedi matin les
gens c'est ça c'est ce qui se dit c'est
sûr sur les réseaux sociaux elle en a
envie
[Musique]
en près de 40 ans d'existence c'est la
première fois que l'opéra de montréal
vend ses costumes ici wifi depuis mes
bras du canada montréal